[Musique]
les enfants bonsoir
patron nicolas et pimprenelle vont être
très content je m'en vais le raconter la
suite du lot jolie histoire
ils vont être bien surpris
avant ni quelle histoire nov je ne vous
le dirais pas c'est un mystère
ou les châles et aux
papas paume
bonsoir
dulapa blanc et du filippi nom de quelle
histoire elle a une histoire de loulou
un instant je me pose là vous savez qui
est loulou oui
[Musique]
exactement
écoutez la suite la première nuit où le
petit foc dormi dans la maison de yann
il fit un caprice un très vilain caprice
guerre le marin pêcheur breton sa femme
et leur fils lui avait installé dans un
coin de la cuisine un grand bac est
plein d'eau de mer une caste sable fin
et quelques provisions
[Musique]
mais appelle la maison fut endormi il
grimpa dans l'escalier
et toc toc toc va frapper à la porte du
petit garçon qui est la rentrée ce bois
lou lou répondit le petit foc en
frappant de plus belle car il n'avait
pas encore appris à ouvrir les portes
mais que se passe-t-il
demanda le marin pêcheur breton tout
endormi
au
petit coquin de phoques au lit et en
vitesse en vitesse loulou glissa le long
de la rampe comme un éclair et plongea
dans son baquet d'eau en éclaboussant
toute la cuisine
le mara pêcheurs bretons se rendormir
le calme régnait dans la maison lorsque
toc toc toc qui est là entrée 5 mois lou
lou répondit encore le petit phoque qui
décidément ne voulait pas dormir tout
seul
le marin pêcheur breton sortie de son
lit très en colère au papa laisse-le
dormir à côté de mon lit un plan ryan
juste une fois il sera si contents et
moi aussi oui moi se dit le marin
pêcheur breton qui avait fort sommeil
pour une fois les foules
le petit phoque ne fuit plus de caprice
cette nuit là
et il dormit comme un nom
et voilà les au fond l'histoire est
terminée parce qu'il est mignon le loup
où tu nous donnes ali oui tiens au mercy
nours je vais le mettre dans ma
bibliothèque je le lirai avec toi
nicolas la prison nous allons y
sert petit
[Musique]
nicolas najati bonne nuit les enfants
fait pour 1
[Musique]
baudelaire bien gai oui patron je suis
heureux de vivre la vie est belle on ne
trouvait pas mais oui north on y va en
rut banni des enfants faites de beaux
rêves
london le rôle de paul paul belpomme
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
en